منذوبات احتجاجات حركه السترات الصفر في
ايار مايو 2018 اتضح ان فرنسا تعيش واقعا
اقتصاديا متازما بدل حقا انه كان يسير نحو
الاسوا كانت تلك الاحتجاجات تمديدا
بارتفاع يسعر الوقود وتكاليف المعيشه ثم
ارتفع سقف مطالبها الى الدعوه لاسقاط
اصلاحات ضريبيه راى فيها كثير من
الفرنسيين استنزافا للطبقه العامله
وامتيازات للطبقه الغنيه هدات تلك
الاحتجاجات لاحقا لكن اسبابها لم تكن الا
عود كبريت قابل للاشتعال في اي لحظه حتى
حين فاز ايمانويل ماكرون بولايه الرئاسيه
الثانيه في انتخابات ابريل 2022 كان وضع
الاقتصاد الفرنسي غير مطمئن تاكد ذلك من
بيانات البنك المركزي الفرنسي في نهايه
ذلك العام فقد توقع ان يتبطا النمو
الاقتصادي في البلاد بدرجه كبيره عام 2023
جراء ازماتيه الطاقه والتضخم اشار
التوقعاته ايضا
تراجع نمو الناتج المحلي الاجمالي الى صفر
فاصل ثلاثه في المئه بعد ما كان في حدود
اثنين فاصله 6% خلال العام الماضي
مصاعب الاقتصاد الفرنسيه جعلت مؤسسه
التصنيف الائتمان
تخفض نظرتها المستقبليه للجداره
الائتمانيه لفرنسا الى سلبيه بدلا من
مستقره
وقالت ان تراجع المرونه والسلامه الماليه
لفرنسا راجع لعقود الاقتصاد لفتره طويله
وضعف الموازنه وتاخر اجنده الاصلاح
الحكوميه واحده من اهم جبهات الاصلاح هذه
كانت نظام التقاعد فوفقا لتوقعات مجلس
توجيه نظام التقاعد الفرنسي الصادره في
سبتمبر الماضي فان نظام التقاعد سينهار
بشكل طفيف وتدريجي بين عامي 2023 و 20220
جاءت خطه الاصلاح الحكوميه ببنود اهمها
رفع السن القانونيه للتقاعد ومره اخرى
الشارع يقولوننا للمره الاولى منذ 12 عاما
ظهرت النقابات الرئيسيه الثمان في فرنسا
ضمن جبهه موحده وشنت سلسله اضرابات لمنع
الحكومه من تمرير خطتها
تجادل النقابات بان هناك وسائل اخرى
يمكنها ضمان استمرار نظام المعاشات
التقاعديه مثل فرض ضرائب على فاحشيه
الثراء وزياده مساهمه اصحاب العمل او
مساهمه اصحاب المعاشات الميسولين
تصطدم خيارات ماكرون وحكمته بمخاوف العمال
والاقتصاد الفرنسي ويترنح تحت ضغوط التضخم
وارتفاع تكاليف المعيشه
وتداعيات الحرب في اوكرانيا